on Monday morning New York Daily News
race centric columnist Shaun King
posited a new change to the constitution
to oust Donald Trump he tweeted quote a
few serious but wild questions one
because the people of the United States
somehow hold the vote now or in the next
year to oust Donald Trump like a recall
of some sort and then he also tweeted
what other ways exist for the American
people to legally oust an unethical
president impeachment only we have long
since crossed a point where real Donald
Trump is so dishonest so unethical that
it is truly dangerous for our democracy
in layman's terms what would it take for
the USA to pass a constitutional
amendment for a president recall like
California has for governor uh-huh
apparently Sean king was too busy
tweeting to read the Constitution you
know the document that answers this
exact question many many times
impeachment is the only constitutional
way of ousting a setting president of
course unless Trump is declared mentally
unfit for office under the 25th
amendment by the VP and a majority of
cabinet officers or of such other body
as Congress provides by law but our
constitutional system was designed to
avoid the instabilities of parliamentary
democracy with its constant vote of no
confidence its constant elections and
shifting governmental powers as for
revisions of the Constitution the
Constitution also sets out how
amendments work but that would require
you know actually reading things it
would also require Donald Trump to do
something so bizarre that VP penseur
House Republicans had no choice but to
initiate Trump's elster he hasn't the
westest area right now is so
over-the-top they can't even wait for
Trump to implode for him to become unfit
in their eyes he was unfit to date he
won here is the truth Trump's Twitter
feed is not a threat to the Republic his
rhetoric may not be good for civil
discourse but that's nothing new
President Obama spent the last eight
years undermining civic discourse in a
far more sophisticated way than Trump
does with his 140 character blass and
Obama undermine faces the government far
more than Trump has which is how Trump
was able to sweep into the White House
on the back of popular discontent the
web can keep dreaming that Trump will
just disappear or they can deal with
reality so long as they do the former
Trump will keep winning it looks like
Trump's winning streak will probably
continue on that basis but just as
importantly the left's lack of care
about basic civics is one of the reasons
politics breaks down our system is
actually pretty durable the founders
created it that way but the left doesn't
care about the system which is why the
executive branch continues to accrue
power Civic ignorance leads to populism
that favors powerful
demagogues if the left ever once read
the Constitution and respected it there
might be an actual shot had a government
of By and For the People rather than an
elected oligarchy every four years or so
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show alrighty so tons to get to
obviously Donald through Donald Trump
tweeted something and that's set the
world on fire and we'll talk about
whether what he tweeted was accurate or
inaccurate or whether it matters or if
the media have completely lost their
mind a lot to get to on that score but
first let's say thank you to our
sponsors over at Mac Weldon so Mac
Weldon m.a.c k wel do n calm mack wells
and calm they sell the best underwear
that is available they sell under shirts
and hoodies and sweatpants it is so
comfortable it is so durable it really
is fantastic fantastic stuff they
believe in smart design and premium
fabric fabrics and simple shopping they
have a line of silver underwear and
shirts that are naturally antimicrobial
which means they eliminate odor which is
really cold and they want you to be
comfortable so if you don't like a first
pair you don't have enough return you
can keep it and they'll still refund you
no questions asked and not only do they
look good they perform well too i can i
can attest to that basically i had a
bunch of underwear from other brands and
as soon as i got Matt Walden underwear I
through all of it out because neck
Weldon is just that much superior to all
the other underwear that i own i also
got one of their hoodies and it is it is
fantastic it's it's just great stuff all
the way through Mac Weldon calm you get
twenty percent off using promo code
Shapiro that's promo code Shapiro sha
Piro if you don't know how to spell my
name by the way then you know you
probably shouldn't be listening to or
watching the show it's exactly how its
down math Weldon calm using promo code
Shapiro sha piro you get twenty percent
off if you use that promo code plus they
will know that we set you okay so
everything went nuts over the weekend
why did everything go nuts over the
weekend because unfortunately we now
live in a world where when Donald Trump
tweets things everybody takes it
seriously and this is a silly world okay
Donald Trump tweets LA to stuff and the
stuff that he tweets is usually coming
straight out of his butt okay Donald
Trump just see stuff on TV and then he
tweets it and that's not the end of the
world that doesn't mean he's a bad
president doesn't mean he will be a bad
president means that he uses Twitter as
some sort of diarrhea
format for him to just spew out his
thoughts and sometimes that's actually
really useful because his thoughts are
useful and sometimes as thoughts are not
but to pretend that every tweet and is
what the media is doing to pretend that
every tweet that Donald Trump sent is
some sort of reflection of internal
Donald Trump administration policy or
reflects the best available intelligence
no no so here's what happens I don't
Trump sends a series of tweets on
Saturday morning he's all mad because he
saw a story in Breitbart that was
basically a synopsis of all of the
various actions taken by the Obama
administration and the DOJ in the run-up
to the election and after the election
with regard to sort of the deep state
going after Donald Trump and here's what
we do be treated terrible just found out
that Obama had my wires tapped in Trump
Tower just before the victory nothing
found this is McCarthyism is it legal
for a sitting president to be
wiretapping the president prior to an
election turned down right in the mini
and mini tweets let me let me find the
exact text because it's hard to see here
a little bit he says turn down the the
turns down by Court is new low right and
then he tweeted also i bet a good lawyer
can make a great case out of the fact
that President Obama was tapping my
phones in October just prior to election
he said how low has President Obama gone
to tap 2 p's my phone during the very
sacred election process this is Nixon
Watergate bad or sick guy and sweet
Elvis out and everybody loses their mind
right and then like an hour and half
later he tweets out Arnold
Schwarzenegger isn't voluntarily leaving
The Apprentice he was fired by his bad
pathetic writings map i'm a sad end to
great show I the reason I add that last
tweet is because this is how Donald
Trump tweets gang okay just get used to
it Donald Trump is not tweeting the best
available Intel available from his Intel
community he's not tweeting government
secrets he's tweeting whatever comes
into his head which I kind of like in
some ways because it means we know what
he's thinking and in some ways I think
while he's the president he probably
shouldn't be doing that but this raises
a bunch of question show everybody loses
their mind so we will answer the first
question first the first question is is
Donald Trump correct is in fact did
Obama order him to be surveilled did
Obama order his wires to be tapped so
that specific charge is wildly overblown
he had specific charges wildly overblown
Marco Rubio was on one of the TV shows
and he says that he's not sure exactly
what Trump is talking about
here the tribe made this very serious
allegation you're on the Senate
Intelligence Committee do you have any
evidence at all to suggest the president
Trump is stating something factual here
by that you mean the tweet yesterday
about the President Obama yes yeah so
obviously i have no i'm not sure what it
is he is talking about half the
president has information that is not
yet available to us or to the public and
if it's true obviously we're going to
find out very quickly and if it isn't
and obviously he'll have to explain what
he meant by it so i don't i'm not sure
what the genesis of val cakes and
there's a ringing defense from Senator
Marco Rubio then Martha Raddatz has on
Sara Huckabee Sanders is another one of
these spokespeople for the president she
is not good at her job here's Martha
Raddatz grilling her over over Trump
sweet sounds like the white house is
really doubling down on what President
Trump as we should also happen if this
happened once again this would be the
greatest abuse of power and over each
that's probably ever occurred in the
executive branch but one of them how
they certainly deserve you just kidding
name down yes if if the President of the
United States said it was a fact he
didn't say I read a story in bright
Barker the New York Times or wherever
else he said just found out that Obama
had my wires tapped in Trump Tower
that's not an if look III will let the
president speak for himself but in terms
of where we are in the White House are
asked you're a spokesperson and I'm
speaking about it right now but but
you're backing off of it you're backing
on how am I backing off of it while I'm
saying that I think you didn't happen
and i think that the American people
have a right to know and I think that we
should get definitive answers I think we
need to put out hard facts that show
that this happened I think we need well
then do it this is the problem okay so
James Comey who's now the left loves
Jim's coming so basically James Comey
bounces around between being loved by
various political parties when he says
that Hillary didn't commit a crime then
he's the best FBI director ever
according to the left then he says that
we've reopened the investigation into
Hillary's email and he is the worst
person ever and then a week later he
says well we closed that
well I guess he's okay and now he's
ripping on Trump saying that there's
this never happened that Obama never
ordered the Geo DOJ to wiretap Trump and
suddenly he's everybody friend again
everybody loves James call me right he's
just the best everybody loves Jim's call
me and then you know and then you have
people responding to Jim Comey sing so
here's Kelly Ann he won't hear here's a
White House spokeswoman is again Sarah
Huckabee Sanders this morning saying
that Trump doesn't believe call me when
Comey says that obama didn't wiretap him
that's why Sarah Huckabee Sanders
spokesperson for the president sir thank
you for joining us this morning is so we
now know that the FBI director has told
the Justice Department that president
Trump's explosive claims are inaccurate
this president Trump accept the FBI
directors denial you know I don't think
he does George I think he firmly
believes that this is a storyline that
has been reported pretty widely by quite
a few outlets the wire typing has been
discussed in the New York Times BBC Fox
News and we believe that here I have to
iron out until I have got to stop you
right there every single artist he just
mentioned does not back up the
president's claim the President Obama
had him wiretap not a single one of
those articles back set up so what is
the president's evidence it does back up
the fact that the administration was
wiretapping American citizens their owns
a wide reporting suggesting that his
administration whether it was directly
ordered by this president specifically
his administration could have done there
okay so there's a lot of wiggle room
here now I'm going to get to the wiggle
room in a second in the fact what
actually happened here but but here's
here's the reality of what basically
happens Donald Trump read some reports
he then did a very summarized version of
those reports that was not quite
accurate and then the media blew up with
it and so every scandal basically
follows this pattern every scandal
basically follows this pattern for the
left okay Donald's from tweet something
it is not accurate but it has a
connection to reality right this is how
Trump operates he says something that's
not quite accurate but it has a
connection to reality the left goes
that's false and it has no connection to
reality and then the right says no but
it does have a connection into reality
and then left says you're all liars it's
fake news in the reckless but it's not
fake news because you know what Obama
was
involved his administration was involved
in asking FISA courts for wiretaps on
people related to the Trump campaign and
then we just repeat the cycle so
basically you end up with one side
saying everything Trump ever said is a
lie and the other side saying everything
Trump ever said was true when the truth
is the Trump says really silly things on
Twitter all the time that are summaries
of a reality that is a little
exaggerated and then the left says
nothing never says is true which is also
really silly and really stupid okay so
basically it's a bunch of stupid people
hitting each other with clubs that's
basically the news today and is this the
end of the Republic is this crazy no
it's not but the media are treating it
like the end of the Republic look at
Mika Brzezinski just losing her
ever-loving mind over this it's really
it's really pathetic and you are out
speaking for president Trump I would
urge you not laugh at yourself because
this is not funny this is really bad
just for the record we're all really
nervous so if people out there feel
nervous we do too we don't think this is
funny Oh give me a freaking break oh my
god what are we going to do Mika and Joe
sat in Trump Tower with Trump the entire
campaign basically kissing his ass and
now oh my god he tweeted something and
it was mean to Obama and it's not
accurate who did you think you were
talking to all these time did you think
that you are talking to the king of
accuracy Donald Trump who did you think
you are yukking it up with this entire
time Mika unbelievable okay so now we're
actually gonna get to the fact so when I
say that what Trump tweeted is not true
but it has a tiny what's relation to
reality that is accurate there's no
evidence to Barack Obama's directly
ordered a wiretap of Trump Tower and
Donald Trump particularly okay that is
not true here is what is true okay
National Review 2 summarizes Andrew
McCarthy to summarize reporting
indicates that prior to 2016 the Obama
Justice Department and FBI considered a
criminal investigation of Trump
associates and perhaps Trump himself
based on concerns about connections to
Russian financial institutions
preliminary poking around indicated that
there was nothing criminal involved but
rather than shut the case down the Obama
Justice Department converted it into a
national security investigation under
the FISA act tape FISA allows the
government if it gets court permission
to conduct electronic surveillance which
could include wiretapping monitoring of
email and the like against those it
alleges our agents of before
and power 5 the applications and the
evidence garnered from them are
classified we would not know about any
of this unless someone had leaked
classified information to the media
which is a felony James Barrett over a
daily wires he says according to
multiple reports during the 2016
campaign the Obama administration
allegedly submitted to requests with the
FISA Court targeting Trump or those
associated with him the first submitted
in June 2016 was reportedly a request to
monitor several of trumps associate the
request was denied the Obama
administration that allegedly submitted
a second pfizer request in October
focused on the computer server in Trump
Tower which they suspected had some
connections to Russian banks that
request was granted but nothing was
found and then there are some reports
that the wiretaps of that computer
continued nonetheless heat street
reported something similar on the issue
so we really don't know the extent of
the wiretaps we know that be that the
FISA Court refused one application and
granted another or at least that's the
report we also don't know whether those
wiretaps were trained at Trump's
associates they weren't trained to trump
himself by any of these reports none of
these reports a trunk and selfless nap
so we also don't know if the information
is being gathered because we were
wiretapping Russian sources and we
caught like Mike Flynn on the line
talking with the Russian so in other
words there's a lot of information that
the intelligence community was concerned
with the connections between Trump and
Russia right but the idea that Obama
himself was dictating from top down that
this is the case that you have to follow
Trump and you have to you have to dig
all this up not any evidence of that but
by the same token can you trust any of
the people who are saying that this is
my biggest problem okay my biggest
problem with all of this is that the
left keep saying stuff like what's the
big crisis here let's just stop there
for a second what is the big crisis here
I'll tell you what the big crisis is
after we say thank you to our sponsor
which is today which is the UFC CA
united states concealed carry
association so if you are very into the
Second Amendment if you want to defend
it yourself if you feel like guns are
the best protection of all the other
amendments then you need to talk with my
friends at the United States concealed
carry association they provide
industry-leading firearms education
they've classes they printing a self
defense insurance so if God forbid
somebody breaks in your house and you
have to shoot them and then you need to
defense lawyer then UFC CA helps you
take care of it and right now they're
doing something really cool the US
concealed carry association they're
going to buy ten of my listeners 10
listen are specifically the gun of their
dreams you're about to get ten chances
to win 1,500 bucks for any gun that you
want just visit defend my family now.com
to answer defend my family now that
calms answer doesn't cost anything no
restrictions you can pick any gun any
brand any caliber you want defend my
family now calm to enter and you get
1,500 bucks toward the gun of your
dreams if you win their little that a
little lottery here it's defend my
family calm defend my family now calm
right now and check it out again you
seca this is cause you know I feel
passionately about I feel very
passionately about the Second Amendment
about gun ownership about the right to
self-defense about the right of
collective self-defense against an
overarching overreaching federal
government us CCA these are the people
that helped make that right a reality
United States concealed carry
association go to defend my family and
now calm defend my family now calm and
check out all the services they have to
offer plus you have a shot at winning
that $1,500 for any gun that you want
which is a pretty awesome deal okay so
what is the big issues the media are
focused on here what's the big issue if
it's just not true let's say that it's
just not true then what's the big deal
so Trump's we did something out that's
not true would this be any grave shock
to anyone hmm there's a guy who tweeted
for three years the Barack Obama wasn't
born in the United States so like no
it's not like no I'm sorry I'm not going
to get all exercise about Donald Trump
tweeted crap but what they're saying is
this undermines the foundations of
democracy it undermines what democracy
is all about democracy was already
undermined folks democracy was already
undermined hey all of the people who are
currently denying that anything happened
from Obama all of those people can't be
trusted so it for example James clapper
was the director of national
intelligence under President Obama and
here is James clapper talking about how
he ordered no wiretap of the Trump
campaign this idea that may be President
Obama ordered an illegal wiretap of his
offices if something like that happened
would this be something you would be
aware of I would certainly hope so i can
say obviously i'm not i can't speak
officially anymore but i will say that
for the part of the national security
apparatus that i oversaw as DNI there
was no such wiretap activity
mounted against the president the
president-elect at the time or as a
candidate or against his campaign I
can't speak for other title 3 authorized
entities in the government or a state or
local and I was just gonna say at the
FBI for instance had it fights a court
order of some sort for a surveillance
would that the information you would
know or not yes you would be told that I
would know that if there was a fight for
court orders on something okay so he's
saying no that's ever happened this is
all nonsense okay I would believe him
except for the fact that here's a chance
clapper had to stay in 2013 in front of
Congress under oath so what I wanted to
see is if you could give me a yes or no
answer to the question does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not not
wittingly there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly okay that is called
perjury what you just saw there and that
guy is out there on TV telling you that
you ought to believe him now James Comey
is saying you ought to believe him now
really did which which version of comas
we believe during the election the pro
Hillary version or the anti Hillary
version nobody knew okay here is the
reality a lot of this is based Trump
what Trump is basing this on is Mark
Levin did a good job on Friday of laying
out all of the various attempts by the
Obama administration to to basically
surveil members of the Trump campaign
here's Mark Levin doing the same thing
yesterday on Fox News and explaining the
case and it's a pretty solid case what
Levin says here the evidence is
overwhelming this is not about president
Trump's between this is about the Obama
administration's spying and the question
isn't whether it's spied we know they
went to the FISA Court twice the
question is who did they spy on the
extent of the spine that is the Trump
campaign the truant transition Trump
surrogates and I want to walk you
through this the American people exhibit
one exhibit 1 this is all public head
street to separate sources with links to
the counter intelligence community have
confirmed
that the FBI sought and was granted a
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act
court this is fine in October given
counterintelligence permission to
examine the activity of quote us persons
in Donald Trump's campaign with ties to
Russia let me go on this is it me they
say the first fighter request sources
say named Trump was denied back in June
denied by the court but the sex out
earlier all these stacks are publicly
reported publicly available we don't
excuse me know what's true and what's
not true at this point so again let me
lay out the chain of events here Donald
Trump tweet something that isn't true
but has a connection to reality the left
says it has no connection with reality
the right says wait no it has some
connection with reality plus he's making
a bigger point and the bigger point is
true and left those bigger point isn't
true and has no connection to reality
okay many things can be cruel ones the
Obama administration could not be
trusted hey the Obama administration
clearly had a had information on Trump
and Russia or wanted to gather
information on Trump and Russia and now
they're saying they can't even find any
real connection they were pushing this
story I mean was being leaked out at the
time almost and and so the fact that you
know that they're saying now that
nothing ever one time that was with it
is not trusted so when people take Trump
is the one who's quashing the public
trust no no one can be trusted no one
can be trusted here and I'll tell you
what I think good about that but you'll
have to stick around a daily wire for
that so if you want to hear more go to
daily wired com check it out eight
dollars a month a daily wire calm get to
the subscription you can part of our
mailbag which will be doing later this
week you can also get the rest of the
show live plus we're going to have a
Shapiro store launching in the next
couple of in a few weeks here and so
you're going to check that out as well
with discounts for subscribers annual
subscribers right now you get a free
copy of the arroyo which is a fictional
film set on the southern border about
the situation where ranchers are having
the land overrun by drug cartels and
illegal immigrant smugglers you'll have
to check it out at eight it's a really
good movie the arroyo made by my friend
and colleague Jeremy boring here at the
daily wire and you get that for free
when you become any annual subscriber
plus other goodies that will be coming
shortly daily wire calm become a
subscriber we are the top conservative
podcast in the United States
you
[Music]